man i used to have sore throats every
single year growing up and i haven't had
one in probably
15 20 years which is good
but i wish i would have had a better
remedy back then because
most
sore throats are viral that means
antibiotics don't work so here you are
you take the medication it doesn't work
and you gotta suffer uh for a week to
two weeks
now sometimes it does come from a
bacterial infection but most of the time
it's a virus
now how do you know if it's viral versus
bacterial
if it's bacterial you may have more
nausea you might have more digestive
issues like a stomachache
but you're not usually going to have a
cough versus a viral
you're going to have a cough
a runny nose
and you're going to have a lot of
swelling back in your throat now the
cool thing about this natural remedy it
addresses both areas
and the remedy is bay leaves okay and
i'm going to show you how to take it but
bay leaves have both antiviral
properties as well as antibacterial
properties specifically for strep
infections so there's some really great
research on that which i'll put a link
down below now bay leaves those little
leaves that you see in your stews or
your soups
have some amazing properties that i want
to go through and one of the properties
that will help you with the sore throat
is that they are analgesic they help you
reduce pain
swelling and inflammation bay leaves are
a great remedy for a cough especially a
chronic cough at night so if your kids
are starting to cough you can give this
remedy to them as well bay leaves have
certain compounds that help stimulate
the immune system that help reduce mucus
that help reduce
headaches especially sinus headaches and
you can use it as an insect repellent as
you're trying to fix your sore throat if
there's insects around bay leaves are
good for wound healing they have
anti-cancer
effects they're good for all sorts of
digestive issues whether it's bloating
or indigestion or even gas and bay
leaves have this unique
anti-cholinergic effect now what does
that mean that means they inhibit
a certain neurotransmitter which i'm not
going to get into but this property
helps reduce an overactive bladder
it helps people that can't sweat
that have vertigo that have dry mouth
that are constipated and if they're
nauseated so as you can see bay leaves
have many different properties
backed up by some pretty cool research
which i'm going to include in the
description now this is how simple it is
it's going to be a tea okay you take two
large bay leaves okay they can be fresh
or they can be dried out and you boil
some water like two cups and make sure
when you boil it uh maintain that boil
for about three minutes okay so it's
nice and hot
then put the bay leaves in this hot
water and let it steep for about four
minutes okay you want to make sure that
the essential oils and the other
properties definitely get out into the
water and it's not too hot to drink now
i would also recommend
cinnamon like a little stick if you have
it because bay leaves are a bit bitter
but the cinnamon will add a nice flavor
and if you want to add a couple drops of
stevia it will make a nice drink if you
don't know about stevia they have a
liquid version of stevia that's a
sweetener and it's from an earth so you
simply want to sip this tea through the
day and you can drink as many as you
want there's no caffeine and it will
soothe the back of the throat it will
get rid of pain it will reduce the
inflammation it will help fight the
pathogens and help speed up the recovery
now this is very very important
there's another technique it's a manual
therapy technique
that i created a video on
that can also help you reduce a sore
throat within about two minutes if you
have not seen this video i highly
suggest that you watch it right now it's
right here